In this segment we look
into the probability
that the sum of n
independent identically
distributed random
variables takes
an abnormally large value.
We will get an upper bound
on this quantity, which
is known as
Hoeffding's inequality.
This is an upper bound that
applies to a special case,
although the method
actually generalizes.
Here is the special case
that we will consider.
The random variables,
the Xi's, are
equally likely to take the
values minus 1 and plus
1, with equal probability.
And we're interested
in the random variable,
which is the sum of the X's.
What do we know about
this random variable?
Well, the expected value of each
one of the Xi's is equal to 0,
because the distribution
is symmetric.
And also, the distance
of Xi from the mean
has always magnitude 1.
And for this
reason, the variance
of the Xi's is equal to 1.
For this reason, the random
variable Y has a mean of 0
and a variance equal to n.
Now, what do we know about
the random variable Y?
By the central limit theorem,
Y has an approximately normal
distribution.
The distribution
is centered at 0.
And also, the random variable
Y over square root of n,
this is a standardized
random variable.
So it's approximately normal.
And so the probability that this
number is larger than or equal
to some a is approximately
1 minus the cumulative
of the standard normal.
So Phi here stands for
the standard normal CDF.
What does this tell us?
It tells us that if we
take somewhere here,
the number square root of n
times a, then this probability
down here in the tail is
approximately constant,
no mater what n is.
And this in particular
tells us that values
of the order of square root
n are fairly likely to occur.
However, what we're
interested in here is not
being larger than
square root n times a.
We're interested in being
larger than n times a.
So we're talking about
what happens further down
in the tail of the distribution.
So if we take here
n times a, we're
looking at this
probability down here.
And we want to ask, how
small is that probability?
Well, we have
Chebyshev's inequality.
And Chebyshev's
inequality tells us
that the probability of Y being
larger than a certain number
is less than or equal to
the variance of Y divided
by the square of that number.
And in this case, since
the variance is n.
This is 1 over n a squared.
So Chebyshev's
inequality tells us
that this probability
goes to 0, and it
goes to 0 at least as
fast as 1/n goes to 0.
However, it turns out that
this is extremely conservative.
Hoeffding's inequality, which
we're going to establish,
tells us something
much stronger.
It tells us that this
tail probability down here
falls exponentially with n.
So this is what we want to show.
And let us get started to
see how the derivation goes.
The derivation relies
on a beautiful trick.
Instead of looking
at this event here,
we're going to look at the
following equivalent event.
Let us fix some number s.
We're going to leave the
choice of s free for now.
It is only that
we're going to assume
that s is a positive number.
And throughout,
we're also assuming
that a is also a
positive number.
Now, we look at this
quantity, and the event
that this quantity is
larger than or equal
to e to the sn times a.
Now, this sum is larger than
or equal to na if and only
if this quantity is larger
than or equal to e to the sna.
This is because a and
s are both positive.
So the direction
of the inequalities
does not get reversed,
and also because
the exponential
function is monotonic.
So this event is the
same as that event.
So we will try to say
something about the probability
of this event.
How are we going to do it?
We will use the
Markov inequality,
where Z is the random
variable that appears here.
So by Markov's inequality,
this probability
is less than or equal
to the expected value
of the random
variable that we are
dealing with divided
by this value.
Now, the exponential
of a sum, we
can factor it as a
product of exponentials.
And then we use the assumption
that the X's are independent.
Since the X's are
independent, e to the sX1
is independent from e
to the sX2 and so on.
And so we have
the expected value
of a product of independent
random variables.
And so this is equal to the
product of the expectations.
So we're going to multiply
the expected value of e
to the sX1 with the expected
value of e to the sX2
and so on.
But because all the Xi's
are identically distributed,
the terms we get
are all the same.
So we get this term to the
nth power divided, again,
by e to the sna.
Or we can write this in more
suggestive form, as follows.
It's the expected value of
e to the sX1 divided by e
to the sa, all of
that to the nth power.
So think of that as being some
number rho to the nth power.
When is this bound
going to be interesting?
It's going to be interesting
if rho is less than 1,
because in that case, this bound
falls exponentially with n.
And so this probability
in particular
will fall exponentially with n.
The key here is that we
have freedom to choose s.
For any value of s, we
obtain an upper bound.
We're going to choose s so that
we get the most informative
or a most powerful upper bound.
So let us continue to
see what we can do.
First, let us write down
what this expected value is.
Since X1 takes values minus 1 or
plus 1 with equal probability,
this expectation
is the following.
With probability 1/2,
X1 takes the value of 1.
And so this random
variable is e to the s.
And with probability
1/2, it takes the value
minus one, in which case
this random variable is
e to the minus s.
So this is the expectation
in the numerator.
And we write again the
term in the denominator.
And we have all
this to the power n.
If we can choose s so that
this quantity is less than 1,
we will have achieved
our objective.
Can we do that?
Let's see.
Let's look at the numerator
as a function of s.
When s is equal to 0, we
have 1 plus 1 divided by 1/2.
That gives us 1.
And then as s moves away
from 0, this function
will have this kind of shape.
And it is symmetric around
0, because we have an s
and a minus s here.
In particular, the derivative
of this function is 0 at 0.
Let's look at the
denominator term.
The denominator term
is an exponential.
a is a positive number,
so it's an exponential
that has a shape of this kind.
The important thing to notice
is that this exponential
has a positive derivative at 0.
What does that tell us?
That at least in the vicinity of
0, this term, the denominator,
is going to be larger
than the numerator term.
And that implies that
in the vicinity of 0,
this fraction is going
to be less than 1.
And we will have
achieved our goal
of an exponentially
decaying bound.
So the conclusion
is that for small s,
we have that rho is less than 1.
Now, we would like to get
an explicit value for rho.
And we will do that by fixing
a specific value for s.
It turns out that if we set s
to be equal to a, then the bound
that we get is going to be
that this probability here
is less than or equal to e to
the minus na squared over 2.
And this is the Hoeffding bound.
At this point, you
may just pause.
Or if you're curious, you
can continue with this video
to see the algebraic
manipulations involved
in order to show that this
expression is less than
or equal to that expression.
But before going there, I would
like to make a general comment.
Even if the X's had a different
distribution but with 0 mean,
the derivation up to this
point would go through,
here you would have a
somewhat different expression
for the expected
value of e to the sX1.
However, it turns out that the
expression that you get here
will always have this property
that it has a 0 derivative.
This is a consequence
of the assumption
that we assumed zero mean.
And because of
that, we will still
have a picture of this kind.
And so this fraction will
always be less than 1
when we choose s to
be suitably small.
And so this is going to
give us a result for more
general distributions.
And that more general results
is known as the Chernoff bound.
However, we will not
develop in this video
the Chernoff bound in
its greater generality.
We will just stay with
Hoeffding's inequality
that gives us the basic idea.
And what we will do next will
be to derive this inequality.
So I'm carrying over
what we figured out
in the previous slide-- and
this is the quantity here
that we wish to bound.
We will look at
the numerator term.
And we're going to
use a Taylor series
for the exponential function.
Remember, the Taylor series
for the exponential function
takes this form.
And using that, we have 1/2
e to be s plus e to the minus
s is equal to the following.
We first write the Taylor
series for e to the s.
I'm just copying from here.
It's 1 plus s plus
s squared over
2 factorial plus s
cubed over 3 factorial.
And we continue similarly.
And then for the
term e to the minus
s, we have a similar expansion,
except that we put a minus s
in the place of s.
Now, minus s squared is the same
as s squared, with a plus sign.
But for s cubed,
when we have minus s,
this becomes minus
s cube and so on.
And so we see that in
this expansion here,
we will alternate between
positive and negative signs.
This means that all
of the odd power terms
will cancel each other.
But the even power
terms will survive.
So what we obtain is the
sum of all of those terms.
But we only have the
even power terms.
So we have powers
of the form 2i.
These are the even integers.
And in the denominators,
we will always
have the factorial of whatever
exponent we have at the top.
Now, let us get a bound on
this term in the denominator.
2i factorial is 1 times 2
times 3, all the way up to i.
And then we continue-- i plus 1,
i plus 2, all the way up to 2i.
And what we have is,
first, i factorial.
But then each one of these terms
is larger than or equal to 2.
And we have i such terms.
And this gives us
this inequality.
So we're going to use
the substitution here.
Because this term is
in the denominator,
the direction of the inequality
is going to be reversed.
And we obtain this.
Now, we can rewrite this by
taking this term 2 to the i
and combining it with the
other term in the numerator.
And what we have is s
squared divided by 2--
all of that to the i'th power.
Now, does this
expression look familiar?
It is of exactly the same
form as this expansion.
But instead of s, we now
have s squared over 2.
Therefore, this is equal to
e to the s squared over 2.
So we managed to
bound this term.
Using now this bound, we
go back to this inequality.
And we have that this is
less than or equal to--
in the numerator, we have
e to the s squared over 2.
In the denominator,
we have e to the sa,
and all that is raised
to the n'th power.
Or another way to
write this is, e
to the s squared
over 2 minus sa,
and all that to the n'th power.
And now, if I choose s equal
to a, what I obtain here
is going to be e to the
a over 2 minus a squared.
That leaves me with e to
the minus a squared over 2.
And then I take this
factor of n as well.
And the final conclusion
is that this quantity
becomes equal to this term.
And so we have
completed the derivation
that this expression is less
than or equal to this quantity
when we choose s equal to a.
And this is
Hoeffding's inequality.